uma das melhores coisas que você pode
fazer para sua família é cozinhar em
casa mas de nada adianta se você usa uma
panela que vai contaminar a sua comida é
inegável que as panelas de teflon cumpre
o que prometem porque o alimento não
gruda agora se o seu critério for saúde
essas panelas de teflon São as piores
porque liberam compostos tóxicos que
prejudicam muito a nossa saúde esses
revestimentos de téflon são feitos de
compostos per fluorados uma bomba tóxica
que pode permanecer no ambiente por
muito tempo contaminando a água que
beber os e muitos nem foram sequer
testados para entender o seu verdadeiro
significado impacto na saúde para ter
ideia do perigo esse composto consegue
se disfarçar de hormônios no nosso corpo
agindo como disruptores endócrinos e não
sou eu que estou falando isso existem
estudos robustos relacionando esses
produtos químicos H diversos problemas
de saúde como câncer alterações no
sistema imune de defesa na tireoide
disfunções neurológicas redução na
contagem de espermatozóides
desregulações hormonais e até inflamação
no fígado